this is for players 1800 above but I
made it a lot harder than that today so
yeah if you're under 2,300 you should
probably leave then you really gotta go
you know come on yeah and turn off get
rid of YouTube you you can't watch this
yeah you at home I'm talking to you okay
so I have several positions and I was
told we would have chess set so we can
analyze no so let's do this all in your
head this is a very famous game which
I'm sure you all know the other ones are
not well known so you don't know those I
showed this a lot because it's just
great I won't tell you who's playing so
it's over it so it doesn't jog your
memory
but it's two very famous players both
sides are queening and both sides have a
queen and two rooks and black played
makes a - which is correct and what's
funny is this move deserves many
exclamation marks maybe six and I put it
on Houdini and it in like one second it
finds it it's the best move and then as
time goes on and realizes how even how
strong it is and much stronger but
basically here white only has one good
move and to solve it you don't only have
to calculate a little bit but more
important than calculation is you have
to have some understanding of the
position this position black only has
one Trump over white and this isn't a
bridge class although it should be I
think I was reading the bridger magazine
this month and the article was just
completely wrong I've never been so mad
it was wrong due to mathematics not due
to bridge so I'll have to email them my
discuss now
do that I didn't email Starbucks my
discussed yesterday so yeah terrible so
the lesson for this today is
everything's terrible okay and this has
been brought to you by Hikaru Nakamura
alright so here white only has one good
move and it wins the game and every
other move is bad so if I asked you the
following question to give you a hint
what's the one thing that's better in
blacks positions and in White's position
you his King this King back rank and
could possibly get checkmated this King
is on the back rank but there's two
looks squares so getting checkmated
would require more diligence on White's
part black would just have to check on
the back rank and then it's made so
based on that long story just told you
what should white play it's a long story
you Queen a six double question mark I
mean triple question mark no after Queen
a six I think I play Queen a four but
there might be analysis which proves me
wrong Queen a four double x clan well
better than I thought
Queen a one question mark actually why
Queen e1 is bad is pretty interesting
Wow defends the g4 square in ten moves I
like that so you know there's a lot of
back rank checkmate with you know taking
the rook checkmate
and sometimes you can take my rook with
check and I play King here and I'm like
well you're getting checkmated so yeah
Queen a6 and Queen b7 both a lot Queen
a4 and you have some long-term issues
there which you don't have if you find
the right move Joe since you said the
right move
yeah h3 the only winning move even
better than h4 though I'm not sure why
so I think as a queen takes H well maybe
later now you don't get checkmated on
the back rank which means instead of
black giving up his rook and then why
try not to get mated why could give up
his rook if he wants and then threaten
blacks rook because there's no checkmate
anymore and that's exactly what happened
so so he played Queen a4 and white took
and now white doesn't get checkmated
with Queen a one takes and Queen B
suffered yeah and blacks gonna have a
very bad end game because he's gonna
have all these weak pawns and a whites
King is perfectly safe and what K blacks
defense wasn't perfect dg8 takes takes
rook c7 threatening g7 obviously black
found a very nice way to defend g7
notice if the pawn was on h4 like if
then rook check Queen takes h4 mate was
advantage so what I'd like you to defend
his Jeep on remember advanced class yeah
you wanted to say something yeah right
that's exactly what happened much better
than Julian who didn't say anything
exactly efore and then white took it and
okay black defended and eventually lost
and these this game was played between
which two players you steinitz and
somebody close course no and Spassky but
you were close and this was some they're
very famous candidates match in 1977
where their behavior was very suspicious
if you thought you behaved badly and you
do they behave almost as badly I was
gonna say more but I've heard about you
they actually keep score okay
so they didn't like each other which
makes a lot of sense because
as easy not to like and they were
sitting away from the board looking at
the demo board then going back and
making their move wearing dark
sunglasses Nakamura style and yeah they
were acting strangely now this match was
won by Corey who was white in this game
but it's actually in the middle of the
match he lost four games in a row but
he's still won the match the lesson is
you lose four games that are all you're
the better player okay that should make
some of you feel a lot better lose a
hundred in a row then here really good
okay so the next game the next semes you
won't know because they're not famous
game that was a famous game next one is
bali offski sockies now sakis was a
great Russian player the Soviet style
but now lives in Israel and well at his
absolute best he was considered a
front-runner with kiss far off for one
of the world's elite but that didn't
happen
belly off ski obviously has played in
many candidates matches lost a famous
one to Kasparov and he was one of the
top 20 players for at least 20 years
this was in 1980 when Valley offski was
near his peak so sakis was very proud of
of what he did the best move his Queen
takes f3 and White's probably lost but
maybe not but he played nine takes f3
notice how material is equal because
material is equal good reason three
minor pieces two rooks and a queen for
each side and now black made the winning
move which would only be for an advanced
class because it's too confusing for a
lower class so raise your hand if you
find the winning move for black now
there's one move that super wins
it's like plus a thousand and there's
one move where it's like plus one or two
plus one or two is it going to do it and
I think most people would suggest the
second-best move and what would a manual
askers say he would say why couldn't I
beat Edward laughs no he would say when
you see a good move
look for a better one which reminds you
of a funny story when I was in fourth
grade science class with mrs. Kirchner
when she's blowing out alive I'm still
mad at her
I turned my test in first thought it was
like multiple-choice 40 questions and I
was you know like an hour before
everybody else and she looked in and she
went on I already see there's one that's
wrong terrible and I couldn't find
anything wrong so I changed one that was
right to wrong so I got 38 out of 40s at
39 out of 40 dad's only one wrong on the
whole test oh there's something wrong go
do it again yeah so actually when you
see a winning move you look for another
winning move your second beautifully
losing so don't do that
terrible anyway what should black do in
this position to get a winning position
anyone grandma the Grandmaster connected
not calling him
yes
Knight g5 is a legal chess move I'm
serious it is I'm not lying
it's a legal chess move that would
attack my queen and I would probably
move it away what's that okay so you
want to play here and I want to move my
queen because it's attacked and you'll
take and I'll take and also it's
possible that I could sacrifice my queen
for a rook and a piece and lose that way
that would be like minus one Queen d3
might be equal but winning is better and
there was a gentleman you've never heard
of I hope if you're in Michigan you
heard of him named Paul push L Paul
Pasha was one of the top five players in
Michigan for at least 40 years at least
and he played in one US Championship in
1949 and I had the pleasure of listening
to a lecture by him once and it wasn't a
lecture he was getting inducted to the
Michigan chess Hall of Fame and he gave
a speech and during the speech instead
of saying thank you and sitting down he
started telling us about his opinions on
various matters and one of these matters
was who was the greatest player ever and
he thought it was Capablanca and he said
the reason kappa blanka was good is
because he would do two things at a time
he would do this and he would do that
and you would see both of them and you
didn't see both of them and you are so
when you played 95 you were attacking my
queen but i saw that but according to my
great friend paul po Chou kappa blanka
would attack the queen but then do
something else so what actually it is a
discovered attack by the knight
obviously but not 95
yes
ninety-five a second vest' and they
would require me to sack my queen for
Rickon apiece then you would win with
great technique Knight f4 is legal but
it does hang a knight so it would be
wrong
so one thing you have to realize which
you probably do realize but you forgot
if you didn't realize it then you're not
suggesting it for no reason why doesn't
rook takes Bishop when a bishop why not
because what what if it didn't hang your
queen
so black should play a move that would
attack the Queen and then rook takes
Queen would not be possible yes 97
now we're threatening the Queen and
we're threatening the bishop because you
can't play rook takes Queen anymore I
hate when that happens
well when I'm white well I'm black I
sort of like it Thanks reminds me begin
that I lost to Dimitri Schneider many
years ago similar tactic and for some
reason belly offski played on forever he
just was down a piece and played on
forever
he played 95 rook takes and then they
just made a lot of moves until he
resigned but I don't really know why
exactly he didn't think the sakhis had
good technique up a piece now sakis was
my longest game ever the guy who was
black in this game I lost to him in 3
days because we had adjournments so we
played and we adjourned we played the
next day when you German played the next
day and I was like oh I think we
adjourned again but I gave up my head of
drawing ending and I lost now this is my
favorite of the batch because I've never
seen the game nobody else has even the
players I would be surprised if they
knew this game and the annotations to
the game are a hundred percent wrong
I've never seen any more wrong so in
this position black white has a tactic
that wins and why played said tactic and
the annotated table wax clam XXX clam
quadruple X clam but actually what he
did is quite bad and what he's doing is
he's taking one advantage and cashing in
for another advantage which is a
material advantage however after he
cashton's the material advantage he was
better maybe winning maybe not if he
doesn't cash in
he's just winning but it's hard not to
cash in because you like to win material
now why is white winning here thanks for
asking
white is actually winning by doing
nothing because blacks position is
terrible and this is something that a
lot of people don't understand about
chess you have a winning endgame you're
up a rook and five pawns for a knight
and four pawns so you're winning and
your opponent's not resigning
so you sacrifice the exchange for a
winning king upon ending that may or may
not be winning what you've actually done
is you've given away a rook for a knight
so don't do that okay
now Spencer's the kind of player who
would see this very quickly and he might
be good enough not to do it
Julian of course would not be he just
thought the player in the game who was
international master did it and they
were he was showered with praise he
ended up winning the game but that's
because his opponent played badly later
so you write question mark or as the
enunciator gave double x clam right
queen c5 wins a pawn but throws almost
all of your damage away right so queen
c5 was played of the game rook c5 check
check check here and whites upon ahead
and white did win the endgame Houdini
says white is slightly better white
might be winning but he might not be
because his king is terrible compared to
this this pawn is not anywhere close to
queening so black has good growing
chances and that's the kind of thing
that if you saw it which most of you
wouldn't but some of you would that you
would play it and that's why ignorant is
bliss 71 that doesn't yeah he won
terrible ah that's better
d6 that's terrible but I lost the
diagram No ah that's the best square so
if you put this on your computer engine
almost every move is plus two for white
because blacks position is so bad but if
you do this combination that's double
last time it's slightly better for white
and the reason is that how do I get
there what and then you got to open
diagonal your king the Queen and rook
could make a battery like here and then
here and you're horrible
the knight is beautifully placed here it
can go to d5 or he six so yeah this is a
black can't move his Knight because he
would hang his neither asieep on so this
is the worst position ever for black
white gives everything away all his
advantages for a pawn up endgame when he
should have just slowly won like any top
player any top player would actually see
this and not do it but this guy was good
enough to see it but not good enough not
to do it so if you're reading is really
law you don't see you then you don't do
it and it's all good so there's there's
a rating range we don't want to be the
rating range here at all of you you want
to be really really bad a really really
good see now Nikki she wouldn't see this
so she played great right she did see
she would be building her position
slowly and winning yeah what I'm
mumbling in the back okay so obviously
it's black to play what is the proper
evaluation of Santa position that was
fast
sorry that's something
we'll let you look a little while
come on Niki you can do it
see I can with I proved it using all
kinds of mathematical something or
others okay who says that black should
win who says white should win who says
it should be a draw who has no comment
no comment wins yeah
and my chess camp since I wear black
could play anything but in this class
black must play here and Julian who was
exclaiming loudly that white wins played
yes Queen takes f7 double question mark
and the game is a draw you were correct
at white winning but you didn't know why
you had that great sense about you
Spencer however plays the move yeah I
didn't look like you knew what F for
incorrect that's where I take this very
good Queen g7 oh yeah that Bishop
doesn't do good at defending me the
reason why it's winning is white doesn't
have a dark squared bishop if you did
there via draw you two opposite colored
bishops but since white does not have
that bishop white is winning Queen g7
threatening mate mate is hard to stop so
you must play must play easy to analyze
though f4 computer would play Queen f4
but yeah so King h5 Queen here mate
King f5 Queen here mate and that's
that's what happened yeah yeah so Queen
g7 winning and the guy actually found it
I can't believe it right okay the next
game is between the two greatest Danish
players of all time
Peter Heine Nielsen and and Matt Larson
yeah and surprisingly Larson won what
you know are just at the end of his life
was was it in too good of shape he was
he he he played in a round-robin and got
0 is his last tournament what's that
he was bent right he also didn't live in
Denmark more than the same hemisphere
but you know he was the greatest Dana so
black is attacking what's not defending
too much but white has an extra piece
what would Alex Avila say if you had an
extra piece cool jeweled wig okay so
black to play and win and Larson found
it well I found him before this position
it's funny the annotations of the game
are by the famous Icelandic Grandmaster
Margar pettersen your favorite
Grandmaster and the first time I played
marker Patterson was a 1988 at the world
chess festival and Saint John New
Brunswick Canada second time I played
him was in 1995 or four who knows at the
Canadian Open and Winnipeg Manitoba
Canada and after that game he was asking
me about Canada and I was like I don't
live in Canada he's like you don't I
should have asked if you lived in Canada
those were like the only two terms
already played in Canada and those like
two he ever played in and we play each
other and both so he thought I was
Canadian and I said I'm not Canadian a
and then I was like ah exactly
Julianne his hand up pretty quickly
which usually means the wrong answer but
nine times out of ten he's right one of
those times you right that's that's how
chess works continued White has one
legal move what's that what's that
no he five is not the legal move after
Queen age two kingi one's illegal move
right right
then you'd so I take it Bishop I guess I
don't know what was your point I don't
show me the mate so I see it right so
show me the mate so I see it
I mean you're making legal moves which
is better than most but I don't see the
plan I mean I see you're giving your
bishop way and your pawn but I'm not
sure why though you have to continue you
get just say create shoe queen chuan oh
yeah that's right you with the right
answer ah I thought you raised your hand
I can't believe you guys aren't as good
as bent Larsen you behind the guy who
thinks I'm saying you h1 to h4 there's
nothing on h1 right now King F 2 then
Queen h4 then I don't know King g2
resigns I would guess he was here for
first class and you missed it
you you missed everything then rook
takes Queen although I would play King
f2 first cuz I repeat then takes Queen I
have a question for you when you are you
when you played efore you were attacking
the Queen why you want to buy Queen to
move indeed I agree
I'm helping you I agree you yeah very
good somebody listens to my hint
yeah large cent played Bishop e4 like
most of you would see he had the right
idea but he didn't know how to do it
Larson actually know how to do it now
you're threatening the Queen if the
Queen moves away from me too that would
be good for black although there's a
rook hanging helps so there's a lot of
analysis about Queen d2 where black has
a big advantage or winning advantage but
he ended up taking it and then
Knight takes e4 check Queen takes and
Bob Boren said that having a thousand
extra pawns is too much and then he
pushed all of his pawns on both sides of
the board and he won they played a 4d v
b6 and eventually too many pawns this
should be forced pretty good because I
knew he saw this [ __ ] before before he
did this and then yeah the King doesn't
have any pawns in front of it
unfortunate and the rest was silly now
this is my favorite one not because of
the correct move which you won't find
because the second best move is
hilarious which nobody would find
including the computer which told me
about it
as making sense was true now these
players every move was double xkm and
then double question mark so chest is
hard okay so correct and white played
Knight takes c6 mr. blacks up a queen
for a piece threatening everything
rawr Knight takes Queen and Knight takes
Bishop check and knight takes f5 that's
a lot of threats now every move was
double X clam and then it was double
question mark
so hard to understand just kidding they
were all the blacks play okay so black
only has one good move who can find it
and if you find the second best move
that's much more impressive much much
the best move anybody can find the
second best move
that's computer only
there's 30 legal moves and that's 31st
also no but you're in the right spirit
of the thing is giving all your pieces
away that's that's the spirit of the
position you Bishop III is the best move
and was playing the second best move is
impossible to find even for a computer
that showed me you incorrect if you
suggest every legal move you will not
find the second best move that's how
hard it is defined that's a heart we've
defined anyone want to guess the second
best move after the best move black is
better after the second best move white
is slightly better correct b4 is the
second best one
yeah I'm not playing b4
all right right yeah anyway Bishop takes
c3 obviously other moves lose okay now
unclear stuff but okay white white took
with a rook which i think is the best
and now b4 is that one of the main moves
so I don't know who wrote this but and
then it's then it's complicated
no that's later actually not then he
played here check takes and now one of
the main lines is B for rook a six takes
takes unclear what but black played this
solid it's reading before yeah
and then the rest of the games missing
but white one yay yeah well put yeah
this should ta aren't you just down
Knight takes Queen you're down up here
just down material yeah be for and
you're down to pawns well look at that
see this is just complicated and crazy
but down material that's even more crazy
and there's a white pawn on a three yeah
if you're gonna go here I take and
j'adoube and I'll give black a bishop on
a five I guess now it's White's move you
but you're down material what well you
give a queen way for a piece that'll do
it and probably be for first is better
well that maybe doesn't matter
and then I yeah I'm two pawns up yeah be
for those what I would play if I had
this position now just to show my
opponent you would expect be for it was
like what yeah this should take say III
though and the game goes on because at
least you get something you're not you
get this pawn extra and be for coming
later than just this happening and an
important variation is this and then
black plays B for Queen takes between
takes b4 and then castles is bad which
isn't surprising rugby one Bishop d3 now
you supposedly Bishop d6 is better first
but I don't think it matters here
mBLAQ's down a queen terrible
and white and white is winning whites
winning anyway I should disappear that'd
be funny for the kid Queen takes and
yeah this is terrible for black because
I said so
in because I'm right yeah this is good
for Wyatt
all right now my favorite puzzle then
not because the positions my favorite or
the moves are good because everyone's a
player's play was double a question mark
so I wasn't playing the game so that's
funny to me if I was playing the game it
would be less funny okay so White's
checkmating black but blacks upon up
okay so what makes obvious move g4
correct and now every move is pathetic
and it's not me question mark double
question we're double quite short all
question mark draw green no thanks I'll
even know if it was the draw black one
okay
yeah now this position is a draw if
black plays correctly but black
blundered what is the only move that
draws for black well the who suggested
hangs everything so now g4 tax tonight
so you can't give the night away because
then you would be down a night
rook g3 correct rook g3 is nothing to
sneeze at
and now the game should be a draw king
h2 and king h1 lose so you have to take
because the Queen comes to see to check
now what do you do
correct the best line is King G to check
and then rug D to double X clam
if King h3 Queen takes d1 wins because
of Queen h1 mate check King h3 draw
Queen h1 Queen f1 draw and nothing I can
do about it because I'll get mated well
the looks good for black Queen check
rook here Queen check work here etc then
you either lose your night and get made
it or you perpetual that's what should
have happened so if like the players
were in this tournament the Sinquefield
cop that's what would have happened
really that's what would have happened
seriously but black played rook F 3
instead of rook g3 okay now White's
winning but he blundered and lost
what's the winning move for white
now this scheme is a not to hit it by
Harvey that's when he wasn't so funny
it's cuz it sounds like a Harvey come on
he says this is the only move but I
don't want to handle his it terrible
alright so White's a playing wind h6
double question mark which was played in
the game so you play as well as the
players yeah the only winning move is
Rick f4 and the idea is black is
actually attacking but you guys didn't
notice that but if you play rook f4 then
black is not attacking so I have to
notice it if it was black to move here
he would play Queen c2 threatening this
rook of this rook and the F pawn was
made so probably you shouldn't let that
happen so Rick f4 get rid of the rook
and white still has all his stuff that
he had and that would win but he played
h6 double question mark and there's no
threat because the knight still here so
now we're threatening check and mate and
the rook was check and so forth so he
played a rip to D to check if King here
what should black do King each true was
not played because of the following
commercial announcement rook h3 king h3
Queen h1 mate with advantage so King g2
is forced Queenie for now more mistakes
here and black Mina moves that winds at
about a hundred moves instead of winning
immediately winning immediately was
better her g3 check terrible rook d3
check even worse
Rock age 3 check yeah that's me that's
the same 8 Spencer just showed right the
other ones probably wind but that's me
so he played some crazy move Queen takes
g4 check the worst and then he wanted a
few moves h6 double question terrible
when Rick f31 it's funny because after
h6 in this position h6 does a threat
anything so how could he not see Queen
c2 attacking like everything used to get
threatened to threaten well we're
talking about checkmate here and you're
talking about practice both sides are
getting checkmate and you're like I
could take an eye even yeah Queen da
Queen d8 wins for white right or D it
also wins for white agreed yeah
the point is black played rook f3
threatening Queen c2 attacking
everything so since these threats are
here permanently we have to stop blacks
threats were kept for gets rid of the
black rook defends f2 the rook on e4 is
that hanging anymore so that's it this
works not gonna threaten anything he's
not going to come in and get you so
instead of white being in a hurry to get
mated he should stop Black's only threat
Queen c2 but he did not there and he
lost right Nikki yeah see she agrees
she's nodding yeah are we winning all of
the games and by the way this is a very
important lesson when your opponent has
threats and you can stop them sometimes
that just ends the game if you both have
threats
and you're hoping your threats are
quicker than your opponents sometimes
you can simply stop your opponent's
threats then you win the previous
example before Spencer was here when
black played Knight c7 he did his threat
but he stopped White's threat also
stopping your opponent's threats is very
important unless you're playing me don't
do it then then I'm just kidding but you
should always stop your opponents
threats and you should think about it
more white wasn't thinking about Queen
c2
I don't think he saw Queen c2 I think he
was like yay I'm threatening this look
how good I am and the director is like
why you can't talk during the game
that's your Queen CJ's like no terrible
it's good that black didn't play rook g3
checked drawing because he played rook F
3 D 1 C so this game was a little
suspicious
not these 12750 s these were you know 24
50 plus tax better yeah for those of you
watching at home this lecture was given
a room right across the way from the US
chess league so hopefully they heard
some good stuff and they can play better
chess
all right see you next time